CONGRESSMAN, HOPE YOU GET THIS
OUT IN THE PUBLIC WHERE IT
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN, ONE
OF THE MAIN TARGETS MAY HAVE
BEEN DONALD TRUMP JR.
HE JOIN US.
THEY CAN'T TELL US WHAT IS IN
HUNT, THE GREATEST SINCE THE
SALEM WITCH TRIALS.
THE ONLY COLLUSION AND ONLY
THING DISCOVERED IS WHAT THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION AND ALL OF
THEM HAVE DONE.
THE IRONY OF THIS IS IF
REPUBLICANS CONDUCTED THEMSELVES
THE WAY I HAVE SEEN THE
DEMOCRATS CONDUCT THEMSELVES, WE
WOULD BE READING ON EVERY
WILL GET FIRED AND MAY GO TO
JAIL, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW.
THEY HAVE BEEN LED DOWN A ROAD
TO BELIEVE X.
SOLD A BILL OF GOODS ABOUT OUR
CAMPAIGN FOR 18 MONTHS.
THE MEDIA WAS COMPLICIT IN HELP
THE DEMS DO THIS.
IT WAS ACTUALLY THEM.
WE NEED MORE INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT THE
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA IN THIS CASE?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE A
PHENOMENAL IDEA.
A TOOK A 20 MINUTE MEETING THAT
WOULD BE STANDARD PRACTICE IN
PUT THINGS IN PERSPECTIVE.
HILLARY CLINTON AS SECRETARY OF
STATE DID 11 ON BENGHAZI WHERE
PEOPLE DIED AND SHE LIED AND
SAID IT WAS ABOUT A VIDEO AND WE
LOST AN AMBASSADOR.
HOW ARE THOSE THINGS THE SAME?
IT'S THE DOUBLE STANDARD THAT
THE PEOPLE ARE FED BY THE
DEMOCRATS IN COMPLICITY WITH THE
MEDIA.
THAT'S WHY NEITHER HAVE ANY
THIS MEMO.
>> WHAT I HAVE SEEN AND LEARNED
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS BORDERS
ON DISGUSTING.
THERE WOULD BE LITTLE DOUBT IN
MY MIND.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
OUTRAGE FROM THE MEDIA.
WOULDN'T THEY READ ABOUT IT ONCE
ON CNN?
THEY WOULD RATHER COVER THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD AN EXTRA SCOOP
OF ICE CREAM AND RATHER QUESTION
A DOCTOR APPOINTED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION SAYING THE GUY IS
IN PHENOMENAL SHAPE WHEN YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT.
ISSUES THAT AFFECT REAL
AMERICANS.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
DEMOCRATS WHO SAY THEIR ONLY AIM
IS TO GET TO THE TRUTH.
WHY WOULD THEY NOT WANT TO SEE
THIS MEMO?
>> BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO ACTUAL
INTEREST IN THE TRUTH.
THEY WENT ALL-IN WITH THIS
CONTRIVED RUSSIA THING BASED ON
THE DOCUMENTS.
HAPPENED.
THEY NEEDED IT TO BE TRUE.
THEIR ENTIRE NARRATIVE FOR 18
MONTHS, THEIR ENTIRE
CREDIBILITY.
EVERYTHING THEY TOLD TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ON EVERY TV
CHANNEL FOR 2 YEARS HAS BEEN
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THIS IS
WAS THEM AND THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION DOING SHADY
DISGUSTING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD BE
UPSET.
>> Tucker: I HEARD FROM A MEMBER
OF CONGRESS WHO IS NOT A HOT
HEAD.
A MODERATE GUY.
HE SAID HE SAW THIS AND
SHOCKING.
MAYBE THE WHITE HOUSE WILL